I saw this story normally we focus on
winners but then I was reading the New
York Times and I saw the article on
Lawson Craddock the American cyclist he
finished last in the Tour de France but
that's really and I've said this before
this is where the story begins because
he continued to ride so first day I
don't know if you're a hundred miles in
and then all of a sudden he has this
horrific crash and Louis R Lawson
Craddock joins us now where are you
right now Lawson my own home base in
Europe town called Girona in Spain so
just got back from from France yesterday
actually what were you expecting as far
as the Tour de France yeah I mean the
race kind of where they pretty much the
opposite opposite and how I really
expected going into it we had a the team
had a race for EF education first had
pretty high hopes for the overall
classification with with Rigoberto Iran
who is our leader so I went into the
race hoping to help him win last place
was definitely not on my cards but you
know everything kind of happens for a
reason at least you know that's what I
think and can't really be too
disappointed how the race planned out
for me I walk us through that first day
when you had the crash yeah
haven't really about halfway through the
stage you know in cycling we don't
really have intermission or timeouts you
know halfway through the race generally
we just have a bunch of staff members on
the side of the road hanging as water
bottles and food and we we blow by I'm
at 30 miles an hour trying to you know
grab them you know we're not perfect the
rider in front of me dropped his bag of
food which sent a bottle kind of
straight into my front wheel and riding
on tires that are less than an inch wide
I hit that full on sent me straight off
the road headfirst into a spectator and
[ __ ] into a ditch I've landed pretty
heavily on my shoulder took the biggest
impact but yeah thanks
that what were the injuries that you
suffered I ended up meeting about six or
seven stitches right above my eye my
left eye and then I fractured the the
spine of my scapula on my on my left
side so fortunately everything was was
stable and secure
Kalama to continue but you know that
things that are still quite quite
painful
not how you want to start the the Tour
de France with 2,000 miles out of you
but also and I I've said this to the
audience that that's really where the
story starts is you got hurt and
probably most writers might not even get
on the bike or there they wouldn't last
the entire Tour de France what was
driving you motivating you to complete
the Tour de France yeah I mean I I spent
17 the summer I spent at home on the
couch watching that you were after
racing it in 2016 and those I knew how
how challenging that was and how painful
that was for me to watch you from afar
knowing that you know I should be at the
race tonight capable and being there and
so for me that the thought of the
thought of doing that was a far more far
more painful than riding along with it
with a broken bone at least that's about
at first but you were raising money to
with each stage weren't you with the
Tour de France yeah and that's really
where the motivation kicked in after the
first stage you know I got my start into
cycling in Houston Texas at the I'll
kick velodrome when I was ten years old
did my first bike race out there and you
know as I've gotten kind of gone through
the ranks of cycling you know all the
way to the the Tour de France yeah I've
always held the velodrome there close to
my heart you know they they suffer
dearly from from Hurricane harvey last
year and I've kind of been racking my
brain as much as I could just to just to
find ways to help help them out you know
repair the damage and also just you know
get more kids on bikes in Houston and so
after the after the first stage I was
kind of laying in bed with Luka I could
I could sit here and throw myself a
little pity
what was me and and feel bad for myself
or I can kind of try and turn this into
something positive you know and try and
make something good out of a pretty poor
situation and so that's where you know
motivation came to start this fundraiser
for the velodrome I
I said I'd put $100 in for every stage
that I that I could finish and at that
point I wasn't sure if it was gonna I
wasn't even sure if I could take the
start line the next day but you know
just see immediately seeing the you know
the support and generosity of all these
kind of willed me every step of the way
now from the stage to all the way to the
final stage in perishing just to see the
contributions that everyone was making
was was absolutely incredible
blew my mind every day and it was by far
my biggest motivator to continue in the
race and Lawson is being humble he
helped raise two hundred and forty four
thousand dollars throughout the tour
what was it like that final stage when
you're going down the Shawn's alizée in
Paris yeah you know it's a pretty
incredible moment you know as a cyclist
you dream up of of racing on that much
on Tuesday and in Paris you know
finishing the Tour de France and you
know seeing seeing you know seeing the
art to transcend the first time riding
on the cobbles you know riding into
Paris you know it's a moment that gives
you goosebumps and knowing that the
fight that I had to get there just to
just to make it there I'll be in last
place you know it's a it's a very very
special moment for me I had my wives my
parents my brother there after they
finish and they're just waiting for me
and it welcoming me so it was it was a
truly special day you know I'm so proud
you know the fact that I was able to
fight through and and kind of make
something better out of a poor situation
and yeah that's a day I'll truly never
forget and you're also running a daycare
center right now I believe it sounds
like that behind you in Spain so we got
kids jumping into the pool outside so
where is the bike that you crashed
no it's pretty incredible I got done
with the north with the torta Fox and
Cannondale is our you know our bike
sponsored incredible bikes you know that
came to me a deal and said look you know
we want to help contribute so they're
actually going to auction off the bike
that I I that I race the Tour de France
on with my number on it and you know all
that all the money that they will raise
from that will go straight to the
velodrome as well so and I'm just truly
incredible yeah it's it's really really
incredible that you know really generous
by it by Cannondale and it makes your
out to be associated with a brand a
brand like that when somebody finds out
that you're you've you're in the Tour de
France and they say oh where did you
finish what do you say yeah our last
placement and proud of it
you know last place of the Tour de
France generally kind of tells a story
of who had that the hardest time getting
there I mean I was four and a half hours
down from from Darren Thomas was the
winner of the Tour I mean that's
basically another stage so I'll tell him
I just wanted to spend a bit more time
out on the roads in France finished last
place and just get some extra training
in you can guarantee that you'll finish
better next year I sure hope I loved
what we were able to do this year you
know definitely I put a few down on the
Chester so that so they say but I prefer
not to go through that kind of
discomfort again but I would love to go
back to the tour
you know rates that have been criminally
and maybe have success in that a
different way as well Lawson Congrats
it's a great story a great cause and it
says a whole lot about your character
that you finished that race and raised
over a two hundred and forty thousand
dollars for the velodrome in Houston
yeah we appreciate your time and good
luck it's Lawson Craddock for more Dan
Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]